françois rebsamen le président du groupe
socialiste au sénat est l'invité de
preuves par 3 bonsoir bonsoir et merci
d'être avec nous un séjour très
difficile on peut le dire pour le
pouvoir des sondages en chute libre
l'augmentation du chômage la
multiplication des plans sociaux et puis
la cohésion de la majorité
présidentielle mise à rude épreuve par
les verts sont ils toujours vous alliez
vous allez nous le dire dans un instant
françois rebsamen
il y également le budget de grande
rigueur ou de grande austérité qui sera
dévoilé vendredi un sujet que nous
aborderons tout à l'heure avec suzette
bloch de l' agence france-presse notre
partenaire pour ce rendez-vous ensuite
avec perrine tarneaud de public sénat
nous évoquerons votre combat une autre
contrariété pour le président de la
république pour le maintien du cumul des
mandats au moins pour les sénateurs
l'application tibi tchèque d'orange
permet toujours aux téléspectateurs
d'intervenir et de poser leurs questions
au cours de cette émission d'abord donc
les verts les deux ministres écologistes
ont donc été maintenu malgré la position
hostile de leur mouvement au traité
budgétaire européen est ce que les
écologistes sont selon-vous encore
membre de la majorité dans ces
conditions là bien sûr bien sûr qu'ils
sont membres de la majorité et que les
deux ministres qui ont été confortés par
le premier ministre sont membres du
gouvernement donc ils ont d'ailleurs
manifesté leur solidarité au
gouvernement et ils sont membres
ministre plat et quand même neigé mardi
un mouvement qui exprime un clean
grillage fondamentale sur les grandes
orientations européennes et sur le
budget je ne le crois pas et je ne le
crois pas je vous remets je perds mais
oui je me permets d'apporter une nuance
une majorité d'écologistes est opposé
aux à la ratification du traité européen
certes mais les écologistes et c'est là
dessus que nous les attendons dans le
terme de la solidarité
les écologistes doivent être jugés en
terme de solidarité gouvernementale
en terme de solidarité de la majorité
sur à mon avis deux orientations
particulières
la réorientation de l'europe voulue par
le président de la république
c'est à dire ses choix européen à lui
oui les choix du président de la
république et et le la loi organique qui
va organiser la
la dépense budgétaire les règles
budgétaires pour les prochaines années
parce que ce n'est pas ajouter un manque
de logique dans l'incohérence si
effectivement des élus verts refusent de
ratifier le traité et votent la loi
organique sur la règle d'or françois
rebsamen là on ajoute la confusion quand
même à pour me pour moi je le redis il
ya deux orientations qui prouve ou pas
la solidarité et selah sue qui seront
jugés il ne doit pas y avoir la moindre
faille sur les orientations budgétaires
que le président de la république a
défendu qui figure dans ses engagements
pendant la campagne électorale et sur la
réorientation de l'europe qui l'a obtenu
permettez moi de le faire et le traité
reste le traité en privé en privé
beaucoup de responsables socialistes
s'indigne du comportement des verts
s'indigne c'est un bien grand nourrit
l'accusent par exemple de de béland
chenille taigu ou de choses comme cela
entre les cas de manque de cohérence
bon ça c'est un jugement que je ne porte
pas sur une autre formation politique
personnellement je me permets pas de
porter jugement ce que je constate c'est
qu'il y a effectivement au sein du
mouvement europe écologie les verts il
ya j'allais dire une même conception de
l'europe
cette conception de l'europe c'est une
europe qui défend plus de justice plus
de solidarité plus de croissance durable
je n'étais pas forcément le cas dans le
nom le traité lui-même stricto sensu et
donc il y a aujourd'hui un moment fort
qui va venir c'est celui du vote de la
loi organique sur le budget sur les
orientations budgétaires et le soutien
que je ne lutte pas elles apporteront à
la réorientation haute au combat que
mène françois hollande pour plus de
solidarité la taxation des transactions
financières
et puis l'amélioration et j'allais dire
du contrôle bancaire
on a parlé des parlementaires d'europe
écologie les verts parlons des ministres
notamment de cécile duflot qui refuse de
dire si elle est pour ou contre le
traité budgétaire ça paraît quand même
sur un réaliste françois rebsamen a
écouté en tous les cas elle fait preuve
solidarité gouvernementale le
reprend pas la position de
europe ecologie les verts dans sa dans
sa position affirmée soutient la liberté
de mes camarades en même temps je
soutiens l'action gouvernement que je
crois pour en avoir discuté avec mais
c'est lui qui pourrait le dire mieux que
moi avec jean-vincent placé le président
ici du groupe écologiste au sénat qu'ils
vont laisser la liberté de vote alors à
leurs sénateurs donc
dont acte ou alors vous les écologistes
n'ont pas inventé la participation au
gouvernement sans soutien c'est vraiment
au jour de la participation et le
soutien
en tous les cas moi je viens de donner
ce que je crois des limites qui seront
la preuve de la solidarité
gouvernementale de l'engagement de la
solidité de la majorité le budget on est
forcément le vote des lois de finances
on est en est un c'est même là
l'essentiel
et puis la loi organique on est d'accord
la conséquence directe pour le reste si
vous me demandez mon sentiment que
j'aurais préféré bien évidemment que
europe écologie les verts que je
considérais comme un parti que je
considère toujours comme une formation
pro européenne qui a d'ailleurs obtenu
de très bons résultats aux élections
européennes il est vrai emmené par
daniel cohn bendit qui a été mis en
minorité si j'ai bien compris
j'aurais préféré qu'il prenne une
position de cohérence sur le traité
européen
tel n'a pas été leur choix je le
respecte l'accord d'y arriver un manque
de cohérence quand même voulu
personnellement je m'aime encore au à
leur ombre on parle ensemble
à l'heure où on déballe en questionner
si je peux encore convaincre des députés
ou des sénateurs
europe ecologie les verts de voter ce
traité jeu je le fais de toutes mes
forces pour autant je respecte leur
choix de partis politiques à carlos
veiga sont déjà là pour le chef de
l'état qui a vu son autorité bafouée
non je ne crois pas je ne le crois pas
ce qui fait la force de françois
hollande c'est d'avoir obtenu au sommet
européen de fin juin cette réorientation
de l'europe
il est clair que nous aurions été dans
une situation très difficile
s'il n'y avait eu que le traité mais
pour sa crédibilité européen
on va voir qui n'est pas totalement
soutenu par sa majorité d'ailleurs il ya
aussi des récalcitrants parti socialiste
on va le dire bien sûr il ya toujours eu
sur la question européenne
c'est une question qui a toujours divisé
la gauche ne sait pas aujourd'hui pour
montrer en 1973
françois mitterrand pierre joxe a fait
hier toujours eu ce problème au sein de
la loge j'ajoute que comme sa droite
pour existe aussi à droite on l'avait vu
au moment du traité de maastricht traité
de maastricht d'ailleurs que je crois
jean luc mélenchon avait voté dès demain
on a entendu jean marc ayrault dire
qu'il fallait un vote massif je le
rappelle sur ce traité budgétaire et je
me souviens que vous même vous avez dit
qu'aucune voix socialistes ne devait
manquer lors de ce vote en octobre est
ce que vous en êtes sûr ce soir on s'y
emploie
vous savez comment la démarche que nous
avons retenu c'est la conviction
convaincre convaincre convaincre et donc
nous avons reçu bernard cazeneuve le
ministre chargé des affaires européennes
nous essayons de démonter tous les
arguments de ceux qui sont contre le
traité et je ne doute pas que cette
force de conviction devrait devrait
remporter une très très large majorité
et c'est une occasion pour moi puisque
vous me le permettez d'appeler les élus
socialistes en responsabilité même pas
mes collègues députés je me permets de
le faire les sénateurs bien évidemment
il s'en fait moins nombreux les
sénateurs à voter non que les députés a
peut-être une voix manquera au sénat il
y en aura plus à l'assemblée nationale
mais nous ne désespérons pas avec bono
l'euro avec lequel j'étais tout à
l'heure de convaincre les députés
récalcitrants de de soutenir l'action
l'horizon la république parce que quand
on veut vraiment soutenir l'action du
président de la république sur ce qu'il
a obtenu qui ne figurait pas j'allais
dire dans le traité sec qui avait été
acté entre madame m était la passion
entre madame merkel oui mais il ya tout
l'environnement qui a changé est-ce que
je dois vous rappelez peut-être on peut
le rappeler que quinze jours avant
l'élection présidentielle on nous
annonçait une explosion des taux
d'intérêt pour les capacités d'emprunt
ou les l'empreinte des français de la
france tout ça ne s'est pas produit on
peut considérer que le sommet européen
de par sa réorientation en termes de
croissance de solidarité financière de
contrôle bancaire
à
apportez une pause cette crise est la
défense de l'euro reste un peu un ciel
heureusement que les voix de la droite
seront là pour faire adopter ce texte
françois rebsamen mais je hausse énorme
pas affaiblir la france au sénat oui
puis en plus moi je vais pas faire de
distinguo en la matière non le dit oui
je considère que ce traité doit être
adopté j'appelle tous les élus de gauche
a voté ce traité et puis si des
centristes il y en a qui soutiennent ce
traité et le rôle de le faire ils le
faire aujourd'hui landais oui ça l'est
pour lesquels mais j'ai vu que une
majorité s'apprêtaient à le faire
tourner tant mieux tant mieux la
situation
monsieur il paraît que vous avez fêté
aujourd'hui un ans d'alternance avec les
verts c'était la grande diffusion
non c'est pas on n'a pas fêté mais il ya
une restera une date historique dans la
vème république
c'est le 25 septembre 2011 le sénat pour
la première fois a connu l'alternance et
donc on a pris ensemble le verre de
l'amitié
il y aura dimanche une manifestation du
front de gauche est très remonté contre
le traité budgétaire et pour qui c'est
synonyme de camisoles d'austérité on
sent que la gauche radicale veut fédérer
tous les impatients est ce que ça vous
inquiète
c'est toujours nos pains quittant mais
regrettable de voir que la gauche
ne rentre pas j'allais dire dans cette
pratique de se confronter à la réalité
du gouvernement et du pouvoir
donc si on veut vraiment faire avancer
les choses moi je suis respectueux des
positions des uns et les autres mais si
on veut vraiment faire avancer les
choses
il est clair que il faut accepter
notamment dans le domaine de la
construction européenne ce qui était des
petits pas est ce que françois obtenu
françois hollande a obtenu c'est à dire
un grand pas un grand pas vers ce que
souhaitent nos collègues du front de
gauche c'est à dire je le redis ici mais
quand même des des centaines de
milliards d'euros qui vont être injectés
dans l'investissement dans l'économie
la taxation des transactions financières
ce n'est pas rien ça me fait penser par
moments à la position qu'ils avaient pu
avoir monsieur krivine et au moins de la
taxe tobin
il était député européen il avait voté
contre alors qu'il avait toujours
demandé parce que ce n'était pas assez
donc on peut considérer que c'est pas
assez mais l'europe se construit comme
ça aussi comment françois hollande
doit-il s'y prendre selon vous pour
regagner la confiance de l'opinion
on n'avait jamais vu un chef de l'état
bah c'est aussi vite dans les courbes de
popularité
oui mais que vous dire c'est pas c'est
pas une surprise la situation
extrêmement difficile celle que nous a
laissé aux bras sûrement parler le
gouvernement précédent et le président
de la république sortant est extrêmement
compliqué extrêmement difficile on
savait que ce serait très dur et moi je
reprends cette formule de françois
hollande elle me semble tout à fait
juste ils ne demandent pas être jugé sur
autre chose que ses résultats
donc il a donné un agenda de
redressement
eh bien on verra les français jugeront
le moment venu mais c'est pas en 100
jours ni en quatre mois que l'on va
corriger cinq ans d'incurie qui a amené
la france à un endettement record qui a
amené le taux de chômage à un taux
record qui a mené nos entreprises bien
souvent dans le mur qui a mené cette
succession de plans sociaux qui se
poursuivent encore en ce moment je pense
comme ça sanofi après psa ses
difficultés elle était là on est
confrontés à ses difficultés
si on peut comprendre l'impatience des
français fort légitime devant une
situation qui est très grave
le gouvernement fait face le président
de république fait face il faut le juger
sur ses résultats sur est pas la nôtre
quatre mois sur sanofi ou les syndicats
dénoncent des licenciements boursiers
est ce que là selon vous peut être enfin
arnaud montebourg a montré qu'il avait
un rôle à jouer puisque semble-t-il le
nombre de suppressions d'emplois a été
revu à la baisse mais mais il joue il
joue son rôle
arnaud montebourg il a il lui est tombé
excusez moi sur les épaules des plans
sociaux en rafale qui avait été retardée
pour ne pas polluer la réélection de
nicolas sarkozy
moi j'ai juste une remarque à faire
arnaud montebourg je profite de votre
émission
c'est certes il ya beaucoup de plans
sociaux dans notre pays c'est la
succession de ce qui a été laissé mais
en même temps il ya beaucoup
d'entreprises qui réussissent
il ya beaucoup d'entreprises qui se
développe il ya beaucoup d'entreprises
qui créent de l'emploi
il faut pas les oublier et j'ai un peu
tendance à ce que a trouvé que ont
noirci le tableau n'ont pas non pas de
la réalité parce qu'il est noir le
tableau et réalité mais qu'on oublie
quand même de montrer ce qui va bien et
il ya des choses qui vont voir même les
entreprises qui vont bien réclame quand
même des aménagements pour leur
compétitivité on va en parler dans un
instant notamment avec suzette bloch
belle agence france presse qu'il va nous
rejoindre
on va d'abord voir françois rebsamen
comment votre fonction de président de
groupe
comment vous l'exercez et comment tout
cela est perçu au sénat pas seulement
d'ailleurs évidemment par les sénateurs
socialistes florence maurice on le dit
ferme avec ses opposants et habile avec
ses collaborateurs son principal atout
avoir les oreilles de l'elysée car il
est ami avec françois hollande depuis
longtemps et son mot d'ordre
le rassemblement françois est un
président de groupe qui laisse parler
permet que s'expriment toutes les
opinions pour lequel n'y a pas de sujet
ou de pignons tabou après
il décide il ya tout juste un an le
basculement à gauche du sénat avait
ouvert une brèche droit de vote des
étrangers projet de loi de finances
pendant six mois sous la houlette de
françois rebsamen les socialistes ont
fait du palais du luxembourg
une sorte de laboratoire au service du
programme de françois hollande
il ya eu deux périodes et une période
très libre septembre 2011 printemps 2012
et puis une période aujourd'hui où le
groupe a du mal à exister dans le
dispositif qui comprend le président le
premier ministre le gouvernement une
assemblée nationale où la gauche a plus
de 100 sièges d'avancé
donc c'est beaucoup plus facile de faire
passer les textes chalco sénat au sénat
avec seulement sept petits sièges
d'avancé et une majorité composite avec
pas moins de quatre groupes différents à
gauche
l'équation pour françois rebsamen est
délicate jean-vincent placé le très
politique chef de file des verts a déjà
prévenu qu'il ne voterait pas le traité
budgétaire européen les verts une sorte
de caillou dans la chaussure des
socialistes dit on au sénat même si les
intéressés ne manque jamais une occasion
d'afficher leur complicité
moi j'ai pas un poisson l'épreuve porte
les problèmes j'ai plutôt l'impression
de lui apporter une majorité ainsi qu'au
parti socialiste et à jean pierre bel au
sein du sénat et commence à bien se
connaître avec eux jean-pierre et
françois et je crois dire qu'on est un
peu dans le même genre tous les trois la
pression c'est quelque chose qui nous
influence beaucoup le contraire reste
que les sujets de désaccord ne
manqueront pas et que c'est avec les
voix de la droite que le traité
budgétaire européen sera probablement
accepter au sénat ça finit
je le prédis monsieur rebsamen doit le
savoir un moment ou un autre aura bien
un texte lourds qui passera pas au sénat
voilà donc vous allez pouvoir répondre
sur ce point monsieur karoutchi les voix
de la droite vous manqueront sur
certains textes essentiels outre le
traité suzette bloch nous a rejoint de
l' agence france presse pour parler
justement bas du budget d'austérité des
questions politiques au sénat et puis
d'autres sujets d'actualité
oui on va commencer par un sujet
d'actualité importants la cour de
cassation vient de confirmer les
condamnations dans le dossier du
naufrage de l'erika
vous êtes soulagé oui qu'en pensez vous
il y avait un risque important il y
avait un risque important et puis ça
aurait été sorte de permis de polluer
qui auraient été données et donc je très
heureux de la décision
il convient de les commenter toujours la
décision de justice avec grand respect
de la décision de la cour de cassation
d'accord bon revenons un peu maintenant
sur des choses un peu moins gai la crise
l'austérité va être avalisée vendredi
par la presse dans la présentation du
budget 2013
c'est une pilule un peu difficile à
avaler pour les l'électorat de gauche
clair du tout d'abord je récuse ce terme
d'austérité
c'est un budget rigoureux ça c'est très
important de bien gérer et la gauche va
bien gérée elle va le montrer historique
c'est un budget rigoureux parce que nous
sommes confrontés à la situation la pire
au niveau économique financier qu'un
gouvernement ait connue depuis des
dizaines d'années et donc nous héritons
d'une situation excusez moi de le
rappeler mais je le ferai
systématiquement nous héritons d'une
situation qui qui est très grave pour
notre pays et donc des engagements ont
été pris par le président de la
république pendant la campagne
ses engagements de rigueur au terme
d'une bonne gestion étaient mis en avant
par la présence d'un public qui vont
être tenues ils vont être tenues mais ce
budget vous allez le voir
c'est un budget qui préparent l'avenir
d'un budget qui définit les priorités
c'est un budget qui va soutenir la
croissance par l'investissement et
l'emploi
justement la croissance 20 milliards de
hausse d'impôts 10 milliards dus
coupes dans les dépenses de l'état
est-ce que comprimer les dépenses de
l'état s'est aussi compris mais les
commandes de l'état est-ce que ça va pas
empêcher la relance 70%
madame blog il savait 70% de
l'investissement public 72%
investissements publics réalisés par les
collectivités locales
or il n'y aura pas de diminution des
dotations des collectivités locales dans
le budget 2013 ce qui veut dire que
elles vont pouvoir et je les invite à le
faire je le fais moi-même en tant que
maire de dijon continuer à investir à
soutenir par la commande publique par
les investissements réalisés les
entreprises et puis c'est un budget qui
préparent l'avenir parce que c'est un
budget qui donne alors ça donnera ça met
du temps on a demandé du temps sera jugé
sur les résultats
c'est un budget qui donne la priorité à
l'éducation ta budget qui lutte pour
l'emploi des jeunes pour ne pas laisser
120 mille cent cinquante mille
décrocheurs en forme décrocheurs
c'est-à-dire sortir de l'éducation sans
rien donc pour moi c'est un bon budget
justement sur les collectivités vous
parlez de l'investissement des
collectivités
la dotation certes ne sera pas baissé
mais elle va être gelée oui alors il
reste gelé les gelées mais il ya
quelques jours le président mais la
critique et le gel devant les
départements de france en disant ça
mettait en difficulté juste 1000 et on
va faire le distinguo dans les
différentes collectivités
celle qui aujourd'hui investissent le
plus ce sont les opci excusez moi à les
communautés de communes communautés
d'agglomération on va dire les
communautés de communes les
agglomérations les communautés urbaines
les villes et les régions
aidée par les départements mais les
départements on va faire face je le mets
à part et de côté à des dépenses
sociales qui ont été transférés par le
dernier gouvernement qui alourdissent
leur propre budget mais ce qui est
préservée dans ce budget pour les
collectivités locales
c'est la capacité d'investissement et
c'est ça qui nous préoccupe le plus
l'investissement parce que vous le savez
l'investissement c'est la clé de la
croissance
il y en
consensus des économistes pour dire que
3% de les sites publics ça va étouffer
ça va étouffer la croissance
même claude bartolone le président de
l'assemblée nationale convient que c'est
intenable qu'est ce que vous en pensez
non seulement de nam mais c'est un
engagement qui sera tenu je dois le dire
ici point j'ai eu l'occasion d'en
discuter et à fait d'accord avec fierté
et avec le président de la république et
avec le premier ministre
ce que dit claude bartolone le président
de l'assemblée nationale c'est que ça va
être très dur à tenir mais oui ça va
être très dur à tenir mais nous pensons
nous d'ailleurs un agenda a été donnée
du redressement quand je dis nous
pensons le président de la république
l'a fait savoir
je pense que le premier ministre dira
encore jeudi soir dans une émission
qu'il fera nous pensons nous que nous
devons tenir cet engagement parce qu'il
y va de parole la france de
l'indépendance de notre pays nous devons
réduire notre déficit c'est vrai que ce
que nous laisse la droite
excusez moi ce que nous laisse le
gouvernement précédent c'est extrêmement
difficile parce les dix neuf titres pour
c'est bien sûr ça ne bougera pas mais
bien sûr cet engagement sera tenu
ouais mais à vous avez là dessus même
mes conversations avec un chef de l'état
en tous les cas c'est la volonté du chef
de l'état on a abaissé volontairement
les prévisions de croissance pour se
rapprocher du du consensus des
économistes et encore si on attendait
attendait un petit peu attendre un petit
peu
suivant ce qui va se passer au niveau
européen c'est vrai qu'on est dans une
conjoncture très mouvante
il faut le dire au niveau européen mais
la droite aidés avait laissé avec des
espérances de croissance de 1,7 pour
cent on n'arrête plus m'en sûrement plus
près des 08 que d un set donc les
efforts qu'il faut faire on les fera un
vous dit aux français on va faire les
efforts ils vont faire des efforts 20
milliards d'impôts enfin la moitié sur
les sur les ménages mais on sortira
guéri parce que certains économistes
effectivement disent on va sortir et
guéri mais on sera mort mais non mais
non on peut la ligne de crête qu'a
choisi le président de la république qui
a étalé je vous le rappelle la réduction
du déficit sur une année de plus que ce
que promettait nicolas sarkozy puisque
l'engagement c'est pour fin 2010 est
d'arriver à l'équilibré budgétaire
0% alors que c'était fin 2016 avec
nicolas sarkozy mais c'est vraiment une
puce asséné non mais 30 milliards
maintenant il se défend c'est nécessaire
c'est nécessaire il aura fallu plus
faire peser le poids de cet effort sur
l'état plus mes économies et moins
d'impôts et le aussi tuer la croissance
de la maigre croissant et l'état l'état
un rôle dans le soutien à la croissance
par ces investissements aussi donc nous
avons aujourd'hui une ligne de crête qui
est difficile c'est à budget de justice
parce que ce qui va se passer c'est que
c'est ce qu'ils n'ont pas été mis à
contribution pendant les cinq ans qui
viennent de s'écouler les grandes
entreprises oui je peux le dire ici qui
vont être appelé à un effort particulier
celles du cac 40
et puis les ménages depuis le matin les
ménages les plus aisés ces français
moyen aussi avec le chef du barème de
l'impôt tni seront concernées on parle
oui oui mais sur ce point où savait que
les décisions avaient été prises en
amont et que nous allons sortir pour les
deux tranches les plus bas là il y aura
une décote pour les deux premiers à la
hanche est ce que vous pensez
inéluctable à terme françois rebsamen
qu'on augmente la cg et la tva tva
sociale ont là où vous pouvez l'appeler
autres autrement parce que c'est associé
à nicolas sarkozy pour alléger les
charges sur les entreprises
j'évacue cette idée récurrente que je
vais ressortir de tva en vient d'annuler
la hausse ce qui était prévu qu'ils
allaient amputer le pouvoir d'achat
parce que le pouvoir d'achat la
consommation
c'est de la croissance de demain donc on
vient de l'annuler c'est pas pour là je
ne sais pas d'où sort cette idée elle
n'est pas parce que certains disent y'a
pas d'autres soleils anglais oui mais
laisser faire le gouvernement voyez les
voiliers les propositions et attendons
aussi parce que c'est un élément
important la résultante des négociations
qui ont lieu aujourd'hui entre patronat
et syndicats l'organisation sociale à
propos de volontarisme le droit de vote
aux élections locales
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est le bon
moment les sondages ne sont pas bons
l'ump a lancé une pétition manuel valls
exprime ses réserves
aujourd'hui même que ce n'est pas le bon
moment qu'est ce que vous en pensez
c'est assez simplement rappelle que le
sénat l'a voté le sénat a adopté ce
texte
dans un rassemblement de toute la gauche
au moins de décembre de l'année dernière
j'avais une belle unité avec les
écologistes
oui puis cette fois-ci vous verrez il ya
plein de textes dans votre avec nos amis
écologistes notamment le budget les
e
les conditions aujourd'hui sur les
suivantes il ya soixante engagements du
président de la république c'est 60
engagements seront tenus mais personne
n'a dit qu'il devait être tenu avant la
fin de l'année 2012
donc ces engagements seront tenus il
n'est pas interdit en politique de
choisir les bons moments pour faire
avancer les textes c'est indispensable
pour les municipales non justement
moi je ne crains pas de le dire si cela
permet je le dis comme cela si cela
permet de démontrer qu'il n'y a aucune
volonté manipulatrice d'électorat
derrière cela eh bien pourquoi pas sorti
des municipales je suis pour le droit de
vote puisque je vais voter je les
portais des étrangers aux élections
locales
cette proposition que nicolas sarkozy
avait reprise par trois fois qui faisait
rassemblement à un moment nous devons
convaincre c'est une belle formule du
premier ministre des esprits éclairés et
y en a au centre et à droite que c'est
pas une mesure électoraliste
c'est un engagement à nouveau droit
c'est un nouveau droit
elle peut attendre la fin du quinquennat
c'est très important vous dites on peut
laisser passer les prochains celle ci si
la bonne foi
s'il faut convaincre de notre bonne foi
de la volonté de réussir cette réforme
parce que c'est un engagement du
président de la république on trouvera
le moment le plus adapté et si ça peut
aider des esprits éclairés en leur
disant envoyés qui a aucune manipulation
électorale derrière pourquoi pas en tous
les cas vous n'avez pas le choix en fait
parce que vous savez que vous n'êtes pas
la majorité des trois cinquièmes
nous il nous marier mais il manque
aujourd'hui une trentaine de voix
d'après les pointages vous dites ça vaut
pas le coup de tenter le référendum sur
le sujet comme ça non non je suis pour
dépôt d'un projet de loi du gouvernement
sur ce texte et je suis pour que nous
essayons de convaincre de trouver ces
trois cinquièmes et donc je suis sûr que
quand on les regarde de bonne foi quand
on les rencontre de bonne foi des
centristes et les gens de droite sont
favorables à cette disposition se
presser comme le dit manuel valls sur la
durée
mais toutes ces importantes tous les
engagements valve sur la durée ce que
les partisans un les partisans de votre
camp du parti socialiste pour cette
mesure les écologistes qui ils veulent
l'application des deux milliards d euros
ils vont pas nous faire je le dis avec
d'humour ils vont pas nous faire tous
les jours une pétition pour demander
l'application de tel ou tel engagement
du président de la république aurait 60
engagement à tenir en valais tenir ces
les engagements qui seront tenues mais
le temps qu'il faudra ou sur la durée du
quinquennat perçoit comme une question
finale peut-être sur gérard collomb
votre collègue et a eu des propos je
suis un peu sévère lors récemment
visibilité j'avais comme les décisions
claires pas d'incohérence l'on dépense
avec des emplois d'avenir retour partiel
de la retraite à 60 ans non moi plus
imposant maintenant ils ont leurs
épouses le savent pas où ils vous
qu'est-ce que je les ai vus aux journées
parlementaires à dijon il a eu
l'occasion de s'entretenir avec avec le
premier ministre
ce que ce soit dur que l'on sait que la
gauche réussisse et donc lille
il dit les choses qu'il ressent et dit
des choses qu'il ressent pour vous la
politique ne manque pas de visibilité la
politique du gouvernement belge espère
avoir démontré un effectivement j'ai
soulevé ce mot et je je je le dis je
pense que collectivement nous permet de
le dire ici nous avons peut-être pêché
par enfin c'est pas un mots que
j'emploie souvent nous avons fait une
erreur de ne pas insister sur l'effet de
traîne l'ère des décisions qui avaient
été prises avant le 6 mai 2012 merci si
cette mort est avec nous ce soir
perrine tarneaud de public sénat arrive
françois rebsamen pour vous interroger
cette fois sur votre combat contre le
non cumul des mandats pour les sénateurs
d'abord sur ce sujet l'anc est
éclairante de jérôme rabier dans la
majorité il y a ceux pour qui le cumul
des mandats est plus un atout qu'un
handicap
françois patriat est l'un de ceux là à
la fois sénateur de la côte d'or et
président de la région bourgogne
le cumul est pour lui une question
d'organisation en moyenne
jours et demi au sénat plus si besoin et
tout le reste du temps tous les jours en
région
si tous les jours en région j'ai là
devant moi le planning de cette semaine
hier j'ai fait la réunion de majorité à
la région je suis aujourd'hui au sénat
demain au sénat pour être à la
commission des finances
j'arrive très bien à faire charge de
cinq semaines n'ont pas réellement
métier mais double métier un avis que
d'autres camarades socialistes trouvent
bien peu convaincant certains en plus le
nom d'ubiquité que d'autres et mais on
peut dire quand même que globalement
ceux qui ont en charge d'un grand
exécutif ont tout de même beaucoup plus
de mal à être présents au parlement que
ceux de leurs collègues qui n'ont pas
cette cette charge c'est une évidence
une étude menée à l'assemblée montre en
effet que les parlementaires ayant un
mandat municipal importants sont presque
deux fois moins présent que les autres
sans parler des conflits d'intérêts qui
peuvent naître de ses différentes
casquettes
c'est normal qu'un maire défendre son
territoire je dirais contre vents et
marées mais c'est pas normal qu'un
parlementaire celui qui fait la loi des
formes ce que son territoire donc voilà
ces conflits d'intérêts qui se pose
qu'est-ce que soit la taille donc une
seule loi applicable pour tout le monde
un premier pas a été fait la semaine
dernière avec la proposition de ne pas
cumuler les indemnités avant de limiter
le cumul des mandats une façon de
montrer la bonne volonté des élus si
c'est ça le problème s'est terré gagnent
trop d'argent
bah oui alors dans ce cas là qu'on n'est
qu'une aller méditer pour la finale moi
ça me va très bien
aujourd'hui les parlementaires ne
peuvent déjà pas gagné plus de 8300
euros bruts tout le monde a confondu ce
nouvel effort ne sera donc pas très
important la future loi devra surtout
régler la question du statut de l'élu
local parfois payer seulement quelques
centaines d'euros car il ne s'agit pas
de décourager des vocations à l'heure où
et prôné le renouvellement de la classe
politique aux questions à notre invité
est venu avec votre agenda comme celui
de françois patriat convient de voir ce
que j'aimerais bien savoir comment vous
maire d'une grande ville président du
groupe socialiste is you soon as avec
toutes les réunions les obligations que
cela implique vous arrivez en plus à
faire votre travail de parlementaires
comme
comme jean-marc ayrault l'a fait pendant
une quinzaine d'années où il était
président du groupe socialiste à
l'assemblée nationale maire de nantes
député et président de nantes métropole
avec une bonne organisation avec
peut-être un sur ce travail oui personne
ne le nie mais je crois être très
présent et au sénat et dans ma ville et
donc vous êtes d'accord avec cette étude
dont parlait le journaliste un instant
dans le reportage qui montre qu'un gros
mandat municipal diminué de 45% à peu
près la présence en commission et dans
l'hémicycle je n'essaie pas de défendre
ainsi le cumul des mandats parce que
pour le sénat parce que c'est une
problématique plus d'organisation
territoriale de la constitution de la
république mais nous ne constatons pas
cela au sénat j'ai fait plusieurs fois
des pointages
vous avez des personnes qui ont des
responsabilités locales importantes qui
sont présents tard le soir
voilà déjà accueilli jacques chacun
s'organise pourrait nous donner
l'exemple
- vous donne la grille de député mais je
me garderai de dire les noms qui n'ont
aucun mandat et qu'on ne voit jamais ou
pas souvent à l'assemblée nationale donc
c'est pas forcément une façon de lutter
pour son absentéisme sais pas comment ça
s'est passé c'est sûrement une manière
d'améliorer les choses mais je crois pas
que ce soit l'élément le plus important
l'élément essentiel parce que vous avez
vous déjà fait passer des amendements
directement liées à votre ville de dijon
par exemple françois rebsamen sait que
c'est le cas on va pas forcément les
dénoncer ici de certains grands élus qui
ne sont là que pour faire passer des
textes en rapport avec leur ville des
parts cantine on sait que ledit là aussi
ce que dit jean pierre sueur par exemple
ceux qui ont été battus comme jean
pierre sueur aux élections municipales
peuvent aujourd'hui se réclamer du non
cumul des mandats six personnalités
comme claude dilain sénateurs qui est
bien c'est très différent suivant
puisque vous savez qu'on a deux modes
d'élection à la proportionnelle et au
scrutin majoritaire c'est pas la même
chose mais nous avons souvent l'intérêt
l'intérêt d'une d'une ville d'une d'une
ville c'est l'intérêt de toutes les
villes il n'y a pas d'intérêt
particulier d'une ville
j'aime bien comme aussi puisque peut
être l'intérêt particulier d'une ville
quand nous votons par exemple la loi sru
quand nous votons la loi sru va nous le
votons pour l'ensemble des villes
j'entends cet argument dispositif
budgétaire qui intéresse
particulièrement un territoire sans le
financement d'une route pour accéder en
général à ce moment le gouvernement s'y
oppose
si ce n'est pas d'intérêt général ou le
savez très bien les dispositions
budgétaires ne peuvent pas être approuvé
sur proposition malheureusement j'allais
dire da sénateur ou d'un parlementaire
ou d'un député
mais l'argument est recevable l'argument
est recevable et donc gouvernement prône
c'est non pas l'interdiction mais je
m'en excuse
jozic mais est-ce que ça fait 35 ans que
et 40 ans depuis 1958 que notre
république fonctionne comme ça des
grandes avancées doit toujours été faite
par la gauche en 1984 sous la présidence
sous le gouvernement de laurent fabius
pierre joxe à limiter à deux mandats
aujourd'hui on parle de la limitation
non pas du cumul des mandats
mehdi cumul d'une lada mandat
parlementaire avec une fonction
exécutive locale
je me permets à l'interdiction c'est par
exemple je connais votre encore on
comprend votre amour pour votre ville en
s'insultant le compte ça c'est clair
notre ancrage local en étant conseiller
municipal comme ça ne vous suffirait pas
oui mais moi je plaide l'impuissance des
gouvernements à vue sur mesure
vous proposera des amendements il faut
accepter ou pas on verra c'est le rôle
d'un parlementaire gelé dire au premier
ministre au président un public avec le
brésil municipal pas forcément premier
magistrat de la ville mais ça ça va être
le sens de la proposition du projet de
loi qui va être déposée par me met pas
d'accord le gouvernement je plaide pour
le sénat je suis pas forcément suivi là
vous avez interrogé quand même un panel
de sénateurs mais je peux vous dire que
sur les 130 sénateurs du groupe social
et ce qui est soutenait ma position
était plus d'une centaine donc oui mais
il à venir mais il y avait gérard
collomb au ciné et d'autres et d'autres
qui donc le cas particulier du sénat je
je moi je suis tout à fait prêt à
entendre tous les arguments sur ce thème
j'ai moi même considéré je vous
conseille vraiment que le sénat pourrait
se différencier sur ce thème de
l'assemblée nationale avec un disque
sans doute d'inconstitutionnalité
pourquoi pourquoi la constitutionalité
oasis que de délais de traitement qui
représenterait uniquement les
collectivités locales ça veut dire qu'on
va on se dirigerait alors vers un
système à l'allemande
oui moi je suis plutôt favorable à une
réflexion si je veux qu'elle soit
globale
le président du sénat n'est pas en phase
avec moi là dessus
oui je le comprends rien il défend sa
conception de l'institution je suis je
trouve ça tout à fait respectable - je
défends une organisation bi caméral le
bicaméralisme avec le bicamérisme pardon
avec à ceignac un français qui
ressemblerait au monde de strates voilà
d'accord est ce que la commission jospin
ou semble légitime pour réfléchir et
proposer des solutions à ces questions
ya pas mal de parlementaires qui
remettent en cause la légitimité de la
commission jospin son jeu pas remettre
en cause la légitimité de la commission
jospin mais
les parlementaires sont tout à fait
aptes à reprendre cela elle modifier
comme cela viendra c'est le rôle des
parlementaires et c'est pas drôle de la
commission n'ose pas claude bartolone
lors d'une conférence de presse ce matin
l'assemblée nationale a dit vouloir
renoncer à son pouvoir de nomination
personnel conseil supérieur de la
magistrature et le donner à la
commission des lois de l'assemblée est
ce qu'il faudrait faire la même chose au
sénat c'est pas c'est pas une mauvaise
idée ça ça mérite d'être réfléchi ce
qu'on veut marquer là c'est la
dépendance totale de la magistrature par
rapport au pouvoir législatif et donc
c'est sûrement une démarche dans
laquelle on peut s'engager oui j'ai
trouvé que c'était une bonne idée à
creuser au sénat d'accord d'aller
proposer à jean pierre bel président du
sénat je préfère quand même que c'est
effet d'annonce soit fait en
concertation
voilà vous voulez dire que ça manquait
de concertation avec le président de
monde est dans son rôle en tant que
président de l'assemblée nationale après
tout c'est son pouvoir de nomination
mais moi je peux pas répondre pour le
président du sénat
un affichage quand même très vertueux du
président de l'assemblée nationale on a
appris aujourd'hui qu'il employait sa
femme comme chargé de mission à son
cabinet est ce que vous êtes surpris je
ne savais pas et je vous l'apprends là
vous me l'a pris la confirme
effectivement en disant qu'elle était en
fait sa collaboratrice avant de devenir
sa femme enfin il est là dans son
cabinet ce que le principe de grands pas
de pas de pas de commentaires je
découvre cette information le débat sur
les collectivités territoriales et les
états généraux il ya une grosse
réflexion engagée par le sénat mais
comment réformer les collectivités quand
les sénateurs et parlementaires sont à
la fois juge et partie
heureusement qu'ils sont juges et
parties parce que c'est eux qui ont
animé jeu par le sénateur l'ensemble des
débats qui ont eu lieu dans l'ensemble
des départements de france aujourd'hui
on est juge et partie et même si demain
nous ne sommes plus que
élu local sans responsabilité exécutive
on sera toujours le juge et partie élus
par les grands électeurs dont tu parles
j'ai lutté bercy c'est exactement ce que
j'allais précisé la différence
essentielle quand même avec les députés
je veux bien qu'on ne reconnaisse pas de
spécificité du sénat mais il y en a une
qui est reconnu par la constitution
puisque les textes qui concernent les
collectivités locales c'est déjà une
première amorce elles doivent être ils
doivent être d'abord présenté au sénat
et donc il y a le sénat elle
représentants des collectivités locales
il est les sénateurs sont élus par un
collège de grands électeurs qui sont
membres d'exécutifs voilà si on allait
difficile pour vous dans galissard
guerre je vais vous dire si on on non
pas du tout parce que vous allez voir
que les propositions ont décapé parce
qu'il est remonté de la base des
propositions moi j'ai jamais entendue
dans mon département qui vont être
novatrice est très intéressante
je voulais dire si on allait vers la
limitation du cumul des mandats on doit
on doit avoir une réflexion globale
1 le statut de l'élu vous l'avez rappelé
mais c'est vrai mais c'est la priorité
on a beaucoup avancé quand même
depuis 20 ans on a bien avancé
aujourd'hui on va on va l'améliorer
premièrement deuxièmement une réflexion
doit avoir lieu notamment pour pour le
sénat parce que à ce moment là je
proposerai un amendement de repli à la
fin pour dire que celui qui est
titulaire d'un exécutif local ne peut
pas être candidat à un poste de
parlementaire
s'il n'a pas démissionné l'année d'avant
pour l'égalité de candidature vous
comprendrez très bien vous vous
comprenez mais je peux vous assurer que
les députés vont le comprendre très vite
si demain ils sont à affronter des mères
qui eux siège jusqu'au dernier moment en
tant que maire et qu'ils ne sont que
député il va y avoir du mouvement dans
tous les sens mais ce que ça suffira à
garder le nom en 2014
à gauche ça ça dépend de notre capacité
à convaincre du travail que nous faisons
et je pense qu'avec jean pierre bel le
président du sénat ces états généraux
des propositions intelligentes que nous
allons faire et bien les élus locaux qui
ont été stigmatisées pendant cinq ans on
l'a vu à travers
dernières élections sénatoriales ils
reconnaîtront les efforts que nous
faisons et les idées que nous portons
terrible on a un partenariat avec orange
et leur application tv de chèques pour
cette émission est là on a une question
de alice qui habite à bois colombes et
qui vous demande si vous allez marier
des couples homosexuels dans votre mail
dijon une fois que la loi sera votée au
parlement oui ma réponse est oui je le
ferai je fais des pacs en mairie
je serai très fier de marier un nouveau
droit j'ai porté un badge de 31,4 et
l'engagement que nous avions pris de
marier des homosexuels
si nécessaire à la mairie s'il le
demande mais ce que vous ouvriez évoluer
le quinquennat après ses débuts
difficiles à ses débuts très difficiles
mais nous nous y attendions vu ce qui
avait été laissée je retourne dans cette
nécessité de la pédagogie les les plans
sociaux certains rappelons-nous psa il
avait été annoncée un an avant donc le
déficit 650 milliards de dettes
supplémentaires le déficit laissé la
croissance en berne tout ça on s'y
attendait à ce point là peut-être pas à
ce point là peut-être pas et donc on
doit répéter sans cesse aux françaises
et aux français qu'on comprend leur
impatience
en termes d'emplois notamment et c'est
là dessus que le président de la
république va présenter un dispositif
avec son gouvernement complet des
emplois d'avenir des contrats génération
j'ai vu qu'ils allaient être présentés
phaneuf restait confiant mais bien sûr
je suis confiant heureusement que je
suis confiant et même je suis persuadé
qu'on va réussir
merci françois rebsamen d'avoir été avec
nous aujourd'hui merci perrine ne pense
voir atos et la semaine prochaine c'est
moi
c'est la première fois donc on se
demande toujours si on voit bien faire
ça va pas se tromper on va j'ai pris le
bon papier trop contente citoyenne
reconnu à part entière les pieds une
émission de la politique ce soir on est
entré dans une nouvelle phase de la
campagne avec l'intronisation nicolas
sarkozy toute ma vie j'ai rêvé d'être
utile à 9 e j'ai pleuré want is you sa
majorité les socialistes espèrent un
rebond dans les sondages au lendemain du
discours programme de très gaullienne
royal la ferme volonté d'employer ce
problème à bras le corps
j'ai la cheville est encore les gens se
souviennent d'un sourire une attitude
une expression d'un geste mme déjean
souviennent de moins en moins de ce qu'a
dit l'homme politique
je crois que je serai élu président de
la république au qg de campagne de l'udf
beaucoup cette semaine et leur
conscience
les voies étaient meilleurs que moi
la présidentielle on a le droit à un
festival d'innovation on est prêt à
faire lourd et bien si on vit plus
longtemps et si vous voulez que vos
retraites soient payées
il faut qu'on cotise plus longtemps
c'est pas marrant d'entendre c'est pas
mal on va dire mais y'a pas un pays au
monde qui fait différemment vous pouvez
chanter tout ce que vous voulez mais
chez nicolas sarkozy vous a cité dans
son discours il a bien fait il a bien
fait mais alors vous allez nous
expliquer pourquoi car il candidat aux
municipales il me fera jamais assez de
publicité il au mieux la république
il a quand même pas été désigné par une
tribune pas puni par un coup d'état
salut à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans cette septième saison dans un monde
de bulles
cette année sans tabou sans peur et sans
reproche on vous propose toute
l'actualité du 9e art et des arts
graphiques à travers évidemment les
séries mais aussi les auteurs quel qu'il
soit les blockbusters et les séries + 1
tunis on va vous faire découvrir ce
neuvième art tellement réputés et
reconnus en france en europe mais aussi
dans le monde entier un monde de bulles
l'émission consacrée au neuvième art
vendredi à 23h sur public sénat
de cet horizon du nid point c'est entre
la corse et l'italie l'île d'elbe qui
est arrivé un homme ce matin du 1er mars
cet homme c'est napoléon qui sur cette
plage où je me trouve la plage de golfe
juan
entouré d'une poignée de fidèles a tenté
ici même un dernier coup de poker qu'il
s'agit pour lui de ravir le pouvoir en
place celui d'un roi louis xviii
installé à paris aux tuileries et
surtout surtout de reconquérir le coeur
de son plein
bonjour à tous dans cette édition d'un
lieu une histoire nous allons vivre
revivre ensemble les premiers pattes de
ces fameux 100 jours de l'empereur avec
ceux qui ici même font vivre et perpétue
cette mémoire la mémoire de cette épopée
le goal fusion nous sommes nous irons à
cannes à quelques lieux d'ici puis à
grasse un peu plus au nord où l'empereur
déchu a entamé sa course folle à travers
les alpes vers paris surtout vers son
nouveau destin
ici à golfeuses sur le débarquement de
napoléon il est très très présent
napoléon d'ailleurs est omniprésent dans
l'ensemble de la ville et tous les deux
ans et bien on reconstitue ce
débarquement napoléonien une
reconstitution un grand uniforme film
métier il l'une des chevilles ouvrières
de cet événement bonjour philippe
lauthier alors vous reconstituer
j'allais dire exactement ce qui s'est
passé ici sur cette plage tout à fait on
reconstitue le débarquement de napoléon
le débarquement de ses troupes
également il faut savoir que napoléon et
partir en hâte de l'île d'elbe la
traversée s'est passée comme d'hab le
mans et le 1er mars 1915 alors que
personne ne l'attendait il débarque sur
cette plage alors on revient sur cette
traversée de l'île d'elbe une île
coincés entre l'italie et la corse
jusqu'ici est ce que la traversée s'est
bien passé pour nous coller alors cette
traversée s'est très bien passé il a
croisé quelques navires anglais qu'il a
réussi à éviter et il débarque que à
golfe-juan le 1er mars 1915 sans avoir
tiré un coup de canon en mer et à un
moment où personne ne l'attendait alors
napoléon a été observé quand même de
très très près juste derrière vous il ya
les îles de lérins et ce fameux port ste
marguerite où étaient présents des
troupes fidèles à louis 18 3 alors ce
jour là bizarrement tout l'état major de
la garnison d'antibes organisé une
visite d'inspection sur le fort sainte
marguerite et ils se sont étonnés de
voir en baie de golf jean quelques
bateaux qu'ils ont pris part pour des
bateaux barbaresques qui venaient faire
une razzia de plus et le général cours
scène dans son rapport dira qu' en aucun
cas il pensait qu'il s'agissait du
débarquement de napoléon philippe petit
qui était avec napoléon ce jour là
napoléon avait peu de monde ce jour-là
il y avait son état-major présent l'île
d'elbe et une
deux mille personnes on est à quelques
kilomètres à peine d'antibes en tibre
célèbre également pour son fort un fort
armée à l'époque et napoléon s'en
méfiait de ce fort napoléon connaissance
intime c'est la ville frontière avant le
comté de nice dont il y avait une
garnison importante et napoléon en
débarquant à golfe-juan il a choisi golf
gens parce que c'était pas tout à fait
un outil mais il savait que la garnison
n'était pas loin donc il a débarqué il a
envoyé quelques émissaires pour essayer
de se rallier cette garnison qui en fait
est resté royalistes
regardez ces bateaux ils sont
extrêmement nombreux et pour cause nous
sommes au coeur du port de plaisance de
gaulle fusion alors évidemment le 1er
mars 1815 il n'existait pas ce port de
plaisance était la plage une plage
absolument identique à celle où nous
étions il y à quelques instants et c'est
ici sur ce port de plaisance de la ville
qui a été érigé dans les années 60 une
simple stèle qui remémore ce
débarquement de napoléon en 1815
j'ai rejoint tout de suite pierre brand
a il est historien il travaille à la
fondation napoléon qui revendent à pour
napoléon est ce qu'il n'aurait pas été
plus simple de débarquer en italie l'île
d'elbe elle est toute proche de la côte
italienne
en effet pour quelqu'un de moins
audacieux que napoléon c'était une
solution au mur à son beau frère aîné
est encore un appui de disposer de 80
mille hommes quelqu'un de logique aurait
dû prendre cette voie là où nord
d'italie où le sud de l'italie
napoléon va choisir la france pour des
raisons politiques mais aussi pour une
raison bien simple c'est là où on ne
l'attend pas donc le choix de golfe juan
n'est absolument pas dû au hasard